foreign
[Music]
the new Super Mario Brothers movie was
only recently released in movie theaters
and it's already clear that it's well on
its way to becoming one of the most
successful animated movies ever over the
extended Easter weekend the movie
grossed an impressive 377 million US
dollars at the worldwide box office the
most successful start of a video game
adaptation to date in keeping with the
Easter release we would like to take a
closer look at the many Easter eggs
which can be found hidden in the film
given the quantity it's unlikely that
you'll be able to discover them all the
first time you watch it and obviously
there's a risk of spoilers for those of
you who haven't seen the movie yet so
beware the first few minutes alone are a
true Treasure Trove of hidden details
the first one is a reference to the
Super Mario Brothers Super Show released
in 1989 which is best known today for
the famous Mario wrap based on a beat
inspired by the video game sound effects
Mario and Luigi rap in a time when
hip-hop was just becoming truly popular
for that time it was very modern in
hindsight however the rap is probably
more classified as crit nevertheless
it's a funny reference in the new film
which is used right at the beginning to
introduce the characters after that you
see Mario and Luigi in a pizza parlor
called Punch Out Pizzeria which is a
reference to another famous video game
of the 1980s punch out fittingly as the
camera zooms out you can also see many
fighters from the original games hanging
on the wall in the background likewise
in the pizzeria you can see Giuseppe
playing an arcade game called Jumpman
this is an Easter egg in several ways
for one thing Giuseppe is dubbed by
Charles martinet who became world famous
as a video game voice actor and as
Mario's voice for another the game looks
suspiciously like the very first Donkey
Kong game from 1981. Jumpman was also
the original name for Mario who did make
his first appearance in Donkey Kong so
basically they've included three Easter
eggs in one short scene here in general
there is a lot of meta humor about
Mario's video game history for example
not only does the film show the games
that made the Italian plumber world
famous but he also plays the game kid
Icarus himself on an original NES
console in his home on the TV you can
also see an R Wing statue from the Star
Fox game series which was also developed
by Nintendo another Easter egg that
probably only fans of the N64 games have
recognized is the design of Peach's
castle this is clearly based on the
original Super Mario 64 game and was
basically only adjusted to the movie's
visuals Luigi has plenty of Easter eggs
too in one scene during his captivity in
Bowser's Castle he is seen handling a
flashlight with flickering lights this
is reminiscent of his own game series
Luigi's Mansion where the exact same
thing takes place of course there are
numerous allusions to Bowser as well the
piano he plays on for example was built
by Ludwig von Koopa as the inscription
shows this refers to the eldest of the
Koopalings Bowser's famous accomplices
from the games were often bosses there
Ludwig seems to have a thriving piano
business so that's a welcome change here
he also makes a very brief appearance
alongside Iggy and Lemmy as a member of
a punk band that performs for Bowser
well as you can see it would go beyond
the scope of this video to go into
detail about every single Easter egg so
what was your favorite eye-opening
experience at the movies feel free to
tell us in the comments what other
Easter eggs you discovered
foreign
[Music]